When you call the nation of Sweden, you learn
a few key things.
"Hi, is this Sweden?"
If you know nothing about soccer, you'd learn
about Zlatan.
"Who would you say is the most famous person
in Sweden?"
You  learn how they cope with low light in
winter.
"One thing I wanted to ask you was about the
darkness.
And you learn about ... foraging.
This isn't dumpster diving, it's a national
institution that a lot of people do.
In the fall months it's mushrooms, in the
spring, all different kinds of berries.
The search for food is a pan-Scandinavian
tradition, but it's so Swedish that the government
issues pamphlets about how to forage well.
And that foraging is part of a Swedish right
called...
In 1994, Sweden added it to the constitution.
It's the right to temporarily stay on public
and some private land, walk on it, and, yeah,
forage too.
The line between public and private property
is a blurrier one than in America.
It can seem a little weird to Americans.
"So if you have private property, there's
no way to protect your berries?"
"Alright, talk to you later."
"Ah, yeah, no I'm definitely familiar with
them. That makes sense."